hi
and thank you for joining today on the
first day of the spectators alternative
conference
i'm not sure what number event we are at
this point so i'm going to give up
trying to say that
um but what i can say is this panel
today is brought to you not just by the
spectator
but by our sponsor for today's
discussion msd the global pharmaceutical
leader
so thank you to msd for sponsoring
today's discussion and making it
possible
and the topic the nhs in a covered 19
world and clearly as we've seen of every
single discussion in this conference so
far coronavirus has impacted so many
parts of our lives
and but i suppose one of the most direct
areas is clearly healthcare
now in the first wave of coronavirus um
steps were taken by the government by
the nhs to ensure that the health
service was not overwhelmed
and there was success there we saw the
creation of the nightingale hospitals
uh not all used but the space in case
they had to be
um but while the nhs was not overwhelmed
i think it's fair to say that
if we look at what happened in the uk
the fact we're among the highest death
tolls in europe
and we are at a point where shortcomings
in our healthcare system
also just you know the way government
functions and
so forth were exposed in the process
so as we head into what boris johnson
has described as a
second wave uh what lessons have been
learned and also looking a little bit
further ahead as we reach further on
this discussion
what future pandemics do we need to
worry about and a lot of people don't
think this is you know the last we're
going to have from that so
do we need to be having other
preparations not just coronavirus type
of pandemics but influenza
and so to talk about uh what lessons
we've learned what steps are being taken
and whether we need to be doing more
and who exactly should be doing it and
i'm delighted to be joined by our panel
today
um i am joined by simon stevens
chief executive officer at the nhs and
dr daron harath
also known as dr champera and executive
medical director
and uk and ireland for msd now i'm going
to start with a few questions and
opening remarks but
we are all very much open to uh viewers
sending in their questions
so please and type them in i think this
is how it functions
uh on the zoom chat and then we'll try
and get through as many as possible
we have to be off air by 3 pm i've been
strictly told so i'm going to adhere to
that
and and i just thought to begin with i'm
going to just ask both of our panelists
just to
give us your initial thoughts really on
what we've learned from the past you
know six months in terms of
coronavirus and what's exposed about our
health system and cham do you want to go
first
thanks katie i mean i think stating the
obvious it's been unprecedented as we
know and i think
from our perspective it's required a
global response by the health community
our sector is a critical part of that
health community and
and our uh overriding i suppose
enduring response has been to maintain
supply
of our medicines and vaccines for our
patients um
the the the output globally also has
required
us i suppose to uh accelerate
some of our uh efforts on that i mean so
for example when i talk about
maintaining supply you know it has been
very very uh
treacherous it's been very difficult and
overnight almost as the pandemic started
we probably had to escalate our
manufacturing threefold
for certain types of drugs without
impacting
our normal manufacturing lines
we've also as part of our response
donated
equipment we've donated ppe we've also
facilitated as an industry
our medically trained individuals to be
able to go back to the nhs to volunteer
and obviously currently now we're
working as part of the wider community
in trying to find vaccines and
treatments to treat kovid 19.
um i'd also like to say i think you know
as
well as that much like other
organizations
we've also had to focus in in maintain
the safety
uh and the well-being of our employees
and i really want to
sort of highlight you know the the
efforts made by especially our
employees in manufacturing who from day
one you know have been doing their job
and delivering their job consistently
uh under quite a lot of stress and
anxiety and and i'm sure
simon will sort of allude i mean you
know the nhs is under probably uh
triple that amount of stress um
i i think msd along with the whole
sector are immensely
uh proud and admire the nhs for their
response it was rapid it was fast
and they launched the sort of major
incident plan to
prep preface very quickly to uh i
supposed to mount the challenges
produced by kerpin 19 uh protecting the
public and patience and i'd say
that you know one of the the main things
that i'm really
proud of on that response is that whilst
it's been very stressful
very uh difficult you know we weren't
overwhelmed clinically by the kovid 19
challenge
and i think that nhs's ability to flex
and adapt to an
ever-changing situation along with the
partnerships we've seen between
government ngos the industry and other
healthcare
providers i i think is something to be
applauded and be proud of and going
forward with this i think and it's a key
learning that we need to capture that
and continue to show resilience in and
playability and and
collaborate have a collaborative
approach to ensure that we
maintain the momentum and build upon on
this um
i i would do say that when you look at
our response though
um that we do need to find a way of
providing equity for all patients
so when we look at the the situation we
know for well
that you know has handled the covert 19
situation from an nhs perspective
but the other therapy areas and other
patients in other therapy areas
um have suffered to a large extent both
from a clinical perspective and also
from a mental health perspective i mean
you know some examples i'd probably say
is
back on may the 30th you know that
there's about 180 000
um patients waiting for for test
endoscopies in particular
and compared to that same time in 2019
that was a 44 increase and also if you
look through lockdown you know there's
2.3 million less
tests to diagnose cancer and 76
less referrals for urgent care and
almost 60 percent decrease in in
chemotherapy appointments so so that has
created
a a a an immediate and important
uh problem for us i mean i would like to
stress
and point out also that you know the nhs
was aware of this and did
uh put in measures in place to try to
accommodate that i think
you know the adoption of digital
telemedicine for example
the way the mhra nice move to produce
guidance and guidelines to help hc
healthcare professionals
to to address these issues uh but i
think the problem is is there and we
still need to
uh expand on that and and look at how we
we capture
ways of improving the patient pathway uh
going forward
um the other thing i'd probably say is
what covered 19 has taught us is really
that
health is is a key component of economic
growth you know
and and we must build on that and the
learnings of curvy 19
to ensure we support and invest
appropriately
in science in clinical research and
manufacturing
to ensure that we maintain our position
as a global leader in bioscience
in in the life science area
and i think that's very key to ensuring
that we are prepared
for the next emergency so as we build a
sustainable
response this time around we need to
that investment to ensure
that we are prepared for for the next
time um
and ultimately i think you know my final
word is that we just
need to keep collaborating you know it's
we have a shared uh
objective of protecting the public and
patients
and it's a priority that we work as a
healthcare community
especially with the nhs to deliver that
um i'd probably sort of say um
paraphrasing uh
some things with george merc who founded
msd um
is is that if you put the patient first
in all our collaborations
i think the solutions that we produce
for the patients
will eventually you know solve the wider
problem if we go forward so i think
for me it's collaboration but it's
collaboration ensuring that we are
putting the
patients right at the heart of all of
this
simon what lessons do you think we've
learned from the past few months when it
comes to the nhs
well i agree with an enormous amount of
what chan has just said so i went to
repeat that i suppose the most important
thing is that over the last six months
we
have collectively learnt an enormous
amount about the way
covid19 works so
we know now about methods of
transmission
much clearer the role that asymptomatic
and pre-symptomatic
transmission plays we know that it's
not an evenly distributed illness burden
across the population
very strongly um age-related so
david spiegelhalter at cambridge for
example has
calculated that the risk of dying from
coronavirus
doubles with every six years of age if
you're
a grandmother in your early 90s then
sadly you were 120
times more likely to have died from
covid than
your daughter in her early 50s so
there's a strong
age component to this there is a
strong uh excess risk associated with
um obesity and other comorbidities about
40 percent of
uh patients who are in intensive care in
hospitals right now
have got a bmi of over
30. there is a relationship between
being from a black asian or minority
ethnic background
over a third of patients in intensive
care right now are from a
main background and uh 70
are male so we know a lot more about the
risk factors as well as the transmission
mechanisms
we have some treatments uh the leading
ones of course which have been
discovered as a result of randomized
controlled trials run very quickly
uh in nhs hospitals uh across this
country which
will benefit not only our patients but
the world and there is this huge effort
underway as we've just heard from chan
on
a vaccine development as well so we know
a lot more
and we're able to respond more
effectively clinically
but let's not kid ourselves we are most
certainly not
out of the woods you know the fact is
that
the number of covert hospital patients
has more than tripled
since the start of this month admissions
are rising
uh rapidly particularly in the north
west and the north
east and so we are going to need
continuing vigilance over the
coming months simon i just want to on
that do you think that we are definitely
then seeing a second wave
resurgence of the virus we are certainly
seeing that
uh in a number of regions across the
country
in that sense it is uh closer to the
situation that
uh france and uh italy
saw in the uh first their first waves as
against our first wave which was much
more broad-based across the country as a
whole
but obviously the concern is that uh if
that picks up momentum
uh across the country then we will see
a lag defect between uh community
infections then showing up as hospital
emissions then showing up as intensive
care and then showing up as
uh as mortality now
there's various aspects of this in terms
of how we improve our response to
coronavirus
and but one of the things we often keep
hearing whether it's from the world
health organization or
various figures on the tory back benches
or even the
government sometimes as testing the
importance of testing testing testing
so i wondered um sham first if we're
looking at i suppose
ways to increase our testing capacity
which is clearly the something the
government very much wants to do
early on i think in their initial
response you saw public health england
uh really relying on their own
capabilities building their own rather
than leaning on the private sector so
do you think that we need to see more
collaboration going forward and cham do
you think we have enough of that already
or is is there's still some way to go
so say i mean i i suppose i speak from a
point of ignorance of not
fully knowing what the arrangements are
but
what what talking to colleagues uh in
the nhs and talking to colleagues within
sort of testing i suppose
you know there is room for improvement
with that doubt and i think there is
room for understanding what we're trying
to do with the testing right so
so i think first of all for me the
biggest problem that i've heard is about
access
and i think also linking up um
the tests in terms of how many repeat
tests we're doing so
so an anecdote from leicester i think
you know that that a lot some patients
were utilizing the testing service
not sorry not patients but the public in
terms of going back to double check
whether they their their their positive
tests had now become negative so
have they cleared coronavirus so so i
think you know
and because the system wasn't catching
up in terms of
understanding that these patients have
had a test it was very difficult to
follow what was happening i think
hopefully the app and and the the
increase in digitalization
of the testing service may address some
of those issues
um overall i mean i i think uh for us
the the the the testing part
now i think is is understanding what the
ro is doing
and as simon sorry said sort of
understanding where
where the phase phase two of this
pandemic is occurring and and
i think putting that you know it's it's
really to help us do our fast response
to mitigate spread to further regions
and externally
um i mean and this is i think something
that
um simon probably can comment on is is
what i have heard is there is capacity
with nhs trust labs and i think the
question
remains is whilst we've centralized the
testing is
should we consider the the utilizing you
know
the the nhs labs also to to take that on
uh maybe in areas where we are seeing an
ro
increase compared to to other other
regions but
um but so i think i mean yes i think
there is
a need for better collaboration um
but for me i'd also say that testing is
only part of the solution so
so it's it's a marker of our
our whether our tactics are working so
so
actually getting encompassed and
worrying too much about the testing at
this stage
is is not uh it may divert us from
actually
finding solutions for other other issues
that are very um
evident with covert 19. simon
would you accept the criticism we
sometimes hear which is that public
health england
and it just were too slow to bring in uh
potential labs that could have been used
for testing in the early stages of the
pandemic
well i can't really comment specifically
on public health england other than that
that has uh now been responded to by the
health department who have brought
together
the public health england functions with
the new
uh test and trace uh service which has
been established under
uh ernest dido harding and that is
obviously a combination then
of um public and private labs including
the
so-called pillar 2 labs the plan that
they are working to
is a another huge expansion in testing
over the course of the next um uh four
to five weeks
aiming by the end of october to be doing
500 000 tests a day
that's um partly going to require a
further
big expansion of doubling in the number
of tests that have been done in
nhs hospital labs as well as uh phe
and rosh and certainly from the nhs's
point of view as a user of
that test of capacity we definitely
uh would like to see uh many more tests
available
not just for symptomatic testing but
also for
asymptomatic for um screening type
testing of the sort that is happening in
care homes right now
but is not available more generally now
that will be
uh greatly uh advanced if we do in fact
see some of the further technical
breakthroughs that have been
widely discussed uh saliva testing for
example it can potentially be done on a
batch basis
uh that would give that kind of scale
but um there is no doubt that uh that
would
be an important part of the defense
mechanism
the country has alongside the
fundamental point however
which is that uh with this type of
infectious disease
uh the number of social contacts that
each of us has
uh is one of the main vectors for um
the upward numbers that we're seeing and
so
you know whatever the legal framework uh
ultimately we all of us have to
act responsibly as people have been uh
in order to keep this thing under
control
and just just on briefly on tests and
trace and i want to talk about other
things of course
but i just wanted simon to have a little
bit of clarity because often we hear
it's nhs test and trace
and then uh i would suggest it's
government test and trace so
is test and trace nhs or
what whose is it ultimately who's in
charge
well the nhs certainly uh benefits
enormously from
a test and trace of the test and trace
program under
uh baroness harding is actually being
run as part of the
department of health uh the nhs labs are
contributing to the uh testing capacity
but it is a
a sort of freestanding service uh that
uh
is has been established for this uh
pandemic
okay so it's a government mainly funded
um
now looking i think and you touched on
this in your opening remarks
uh we have a situation where clearly
we're going into what could become a
very intense period for hospitals in
terms of coronavirus again
though as simon and yourself have
discussed in a way we are better
prepared for lessons that we have
learned
um but we already have you know long
waiting list for cancer treatments for
other treatments
that's coming up the track what do you
think can be done
ultimately we are now living with
coronavirus and also if we look at what
the chancellor said last week
um it does feel as though we are with
this disease for the long haul we're not
expecting
to be rid of it anytime soon so how can
the nhs and other health services better
and balance coronavirus focusing
treatments with
uh treatments which ultimately without
which we could end up in a situation
with a
very high death toll so cancer and so
forth
i mean i i don't think uh i or all
my sector probably have the the direct
answer that i think
this is where i think collaboration has
to come in and
and we have to find our route through
and i i'd stress that
you know a bit like with testing we need
to find a sustainable solution
so um it's not enough to find something
that will
get us through the next few months um
i'd say to approach it though we do need
to
to i think there's there's a large piece
before we even get on to
looking at the patient pathways about
reassuring the patients themselves
right so so there is a immense amount of
anxiety
we can underestimate amongst patients
and especially based on the letters that
we went out at the beginning of the
lockdown you know asking people to
self-isolate
asking people to shield that actually
those were generic sort of i suppose
letters based on a
on a diagnosis and work particular to
the individual
so so i think we have to address how do
we
um you know give reassurance and and
also give bespoke advice to individual
patients so
is that through uh you know further sort
of you know
outpatient telemedicine sort of
appointments is that through
further uh correspondence after that i
think then it's
actually as nice started doing
is looking at sort of i suppose
treatment pathways
that minimize the risk in terms of to
patients and and
uh the healthcare professionals so you
know sort of for example if you talk
about cancer therapies
looking for cancer therapies where we
know when we have good safety and
efficacy data that allow
them to dosed at sort of less frequent
intervals
and therefore the patients can receive
treatment and then ultimately i think
the third
part we need to solve for is is how does
all the anxiety services work for
for example one of the the after effects
of covid19
is that you know ex radiology services
are working really well as
someone will know however because of the
requirements of covid19
in terms of protection of of patients
and
health professionals you know a chest
x-ray itself now takes much much longer
and finally what i'd also say is going
back to my point about patients i think
is that i saw some data also that um
from a selection of gp practices
that had video capability so they could
talk to patient
and have a better informed uh
conversation with the patient
however 76 patients percent of those
patients
preferred not to have video on you know
so i think with all of these things we
do need to
keep checking as to what's acceptable by
patients and the public
um and not to try to impose a
solutions that we believe to be better
in that perspective
and simon on that i mean you've said how
the nhs is preparing the second wave
escalation plans
but ultimately uh trying to unlock them
as late as possible because you want to
make sure that we do get that
non-coronavirus care so
how is that balancing process going on
are you worried about what's happening
in terms of cancer wait lists
so we've had a window of opportunity
which we
are using to the fall to um expand
non-coronavirus related services
since the start of the pandemic
hospitals have looked after
over a hundred and eleven thousand uh
covid patients who've needed their
specialist care
but i think it's worth just noting that
even at the height of covid
in april for every coronavirus patient
in hospital there were two
other non-coronavirus patients getting
looked after so
although it clearly did have an impact
it's not true that the nhs was ever a
covet only
service but that said it has
obviously had an impact on care for the
reasons that chan has described and so
the ramp back up is now well underway
across the nhs we are
um we believe that uh given uh this time
round
there's more um certainty as to the type
of uh
requirements that coronavirus patients
are going to have uh we are not
confronted with the
situation we were in early march where
you know frankly when you looked at
those scenes in hospitals in
northern italy being overrun uh with
patients who weren't able to get uh
care in intensive care you know we went
from a situation where we had a few
hundred coronavirus impatience
uh in mid-march uh to 11 000
a fortnight later and then 18 000 a week
after that
um you know the modeling from various of
the groups uh suggested that that could
continue to spiral out of control
i think we're we're much better placed
this time around but the reality is the
inescapable reality is that if there is
a
huge upsurge in coronavirus infection in
the community
then patients will need inpatient care
but what we are moving heaven and earth
to do
is to make sure that our other services
including cancer care as we've talked
about
um get back on track during
march april may june july actually
the nhs was able to offer 85 percent of
the usual level of cancer
treatments some of those were deferred
because
patients and their clinicians came to
the view that it would be more risky to
embark on a
immunosuppressing course of treatment at
the time there was so much
uh infection around in the community
some of it because of the
capacity constraints that uh chan
described
but we really want to try and uh sustain
uh that full range of other services
uh to the greatest possible extent that
we can
thank you um now do you send any
questions you have just enter the chat
function and we'll try and get for as
many as possible
in due course um i think i suppose
looking at uh
the various balancing acts in terms of
uh things we need to do uh services that
nhs has to
offer i just want to ask briefly um
simon one of the things that's been in
the news a lot is ultimately birthing
partners
and campaigned by the men on sunday at
the moment about making that more
possible
now it depends it seems depends what nh
trust you you're at
depending on whether or not you're
allowed to bring someone in with you if
you're
uh pregnant and uh to give birth so is
there any update on that is more work
being done
because it's something causing quite a
lot uh anguish
yeah i mean the position throughout uh
the
uh pandemic so far uh
the national uh advice to hospitals was
that uh they should
always permit uh birthing partners to be
their fathers
partners uh during uh labor and
childbirth
but we have um issued a uh further
reminder two hospitals the chief
midwifery officer
jackie dunkley bent and matthew jolly
the national
clinical director for obstetrics have
written two hospitals
reminding them of that and also wherever
possible
the importance of partners being able to
come to uh antenatal visits uh for scans
checkups and so on so
we definitely would like to see that
right across
the maternity units
okay i've got some personal experience
of this because my son was born
in august actually so i've gone through
that process
he's our third child and i probably say
you know in
in um you know in defense of the nhs
i think it's obviously a very difficult
situation and i think we found obviously
you know
the scans my partner she had to go by
herself and so forth so
you know there was a lot of anxiety and
her and i did reflect that actually the
levels of anxiety if this was our first
child would have been much more
heightened
and i think this is where also uh from a
healthcare professional perspective that
providing a a solution that may be one
size fits all
it's probably uh you know sometimes not
the way to go where
actually you probably need to spend more
time with with those uh
um parents there are uh first time in in
terms of
childbirth um compared to the you know
some of us who are
probably about sort of you know third
time or second time
there and i think it's important that
when we approach this and i think cha
maternity service are a good example
that we do try to still maintain
that patient-centric approach in terms
of understanding
what the patient needs might be so you
know it is
it was just a point that i probably
throw in because i think
you know whilst we can get caught up
with the pandemic and say look we can't
really
we need to address it as an urgent
matter i think still make trying to
maintain that will alleviate
some of these uh anxieties and
misunderstandings as i'd say
now i just want to go to one audience
question because it was on a topic that
i
was hoping to move to which is
ultimately a huge part of the
coronavirus response for looking at
coronavirus specifically is care homes
and
what happened the last time around um
working together so i mentioned earlier
the testing being used in care homes
so um steph asks what provisions are
being made for the care service
so we don't send covered patients into
the care system and i suppose it can
also be what provision should be
i'm not sure who wants to go first on
that
yeah um well i think the questioner is
quite right
and what we've seen in care homes not
just in this country but actually
in uh germany and uh scotland and
uh sweden and a number of other
countries is that they have been
disproportionately hit by
coronavirus and that's not just
explained by the fact that
there are a concentration of older
people in care homes and there's this
strong age
uh curve to the risk factor
so i think um the there are sort of
various
layers to uh what is the the
government's response and support for
care homes now first of all they have
been getting
um more uh weekly uh
testing uh than actually uh any other
part of
uh the country and that's very important
to be able to
quickly identify where there are
outbreaks
secondly matt hancock has
said that he will be making available
continue to make available
ppe for care homes together with the
training
support that they've been getting from
the local nhs
thirdly it is increasingly clear from
the
various studies not just in this country
but internationally
that a lot of the problem with the
infection outbreaks in care homes was
from the movement of staff between care
homes and from the community into
into care homes a set of studies called
the valdez studies
uh another piece of work from uh public
health whales uh within the last couple
of weeks have all highlighted that
so making sure that care homes have got
the support so that
they've got the staff that they need and
they can create these
uh bubbles if you like to prevent the
spread of infection
is going to be crucially important and
then there's a very important role as
well for local authorities
uh in ensuring that there are
appropriate isolation or quarantine
periods for people coming into
care homes as they as you get movement
of people residents
in different parts of the care system so
i think all of those are laid out
uh the department of health uh published
uh
what they called their uh uh covert 19
winter plan for adult social care on the
18th of september and
it's all set out in there and
i just forgot to tell his thoughts on
this i just wondered one of the things
that you often hear in the debate around
coronavirus is this idea that we should
be
shielding not all you know segmenting
parts of the population
and so the idea being if you look at
scenes right now where we have lots of
students uh trapped in their halls
i'm not having the best freshers week i
think it's fair to say um
lots of people say well actually why why
is that happening why don't we take uh
more elderly groups groups higher risk
and close them off i just want to simon
do you think when you look that's
something that using would be viable the
prime minister said that he didn't think
it would work and
chris whittier said similar well
i mean i think there's a nuanced answer
to that isn't there
i mean clearly um if you are
you know my parents are needs to take
particular care and and indeed
and indeed they are um so
that's part of the reason why there was
the identification of people who were
uh clinically extremely vulnerable and
older groups uh
first time around with particular
protections
uh for them um however that is not the
same as saying that by
itself that is a strategy that can
succeed and
indeed even if you look at the way in
which
infections are spreading across
the northwest of england right now you
can see them beginning to ripple up the
age
curve so the idea that you could uh you
know completely
uh separate the fifth of the population
who are
aged over 65 say i think is implausible
not least because uh for some of the
most vulnerable they will be getting
help from working age adults some of
whom will be younger and some of whom
will be living in households with
younger people and so forth so
um you know that's just not the way the
world works and in any event there would
be legitimate concern about
the social isolation uh that you know is
giving rise for example to this
very understandable discussion about
whether there should have you know how
much visiting you can do in cairns for
example so
um i think uh that in a nutshell
um extra precautions for those at
greatest risk
is clearly a sensible part of the mix
but by
itself we're not going to have age-based
apartheid across this country
chad what are your thoughts on that and
i've got lots of questions
coming in now just so quickly so i'm not
so much back to that i mean i i
i totally agree with what simon says i
think pretty eloquently because the
novel thing about coronavirus
is the fact that most of us you know
will
have a very asymptomatic disease or very
few symptoms right but it
there is a percentage of a very small
percentage of age-related and
potentially some other
markers that will have a very negative
outcome
and i think this this goes back to the
point that we make that we all need to
be working together
and be vigilant your pandemic response
is only as good as your weakest
aspect you know so so therefore you know
we can't create sort of as as simon put
it in apartheid for
the elderly uh population members i
think
you have to approach it from an overall
population
and it's all you know it is all our duty
to ensure that we take precautions
yeah quite a few questions coming in so
if you do have any more questions do you
get them in
asap so your time to get to you and
here's one i
think we'll go to you first on this
channel which is from james patricia
hodge
post coronavirus will there be a new
balance of nhs and private partnerships
um i i hope so so i'll say
say from that point of view not not from
a production point of view but i think
what covid 19 has allowed us to do is
we've i suppose
had to break down sort of mistrust that
might have existed in in
places and for me i think we are
demonstrating that collaboration is
possible
we are also demonstrating that even when
it comes to treatments for example that
we can move faster
on uh deciding about newer treatment
pathways and so forth and
for me um the simple answer is that we
need to maintain
that that level of trust we're building
up maintain the dialogue especially in
terms of where we are
and then going ahead i think uh without
doubt i think it is required
um and i think the the other the
impending i suppose
requirement is is the fact of of of
other potential emergencies and other
pandemics
so it i mean i'd like to be optimistic
but
and say there won't be any but i think i
think the reality of it is
there will be you know simon do you have
anything to add on that before we go to
more questions
well i would just underline two two
things perhaps uh the first is that
the nhs one of the things we've done
very uh quickly
when a coronavirus kicked off was a
partnership with independent
hospitals uh independent uh diagnostics
companies
uh across england and have been
able to ensure that uh nhs patients so
they're able to get
access to those services that's a
partnership that we expect to continue
and we'll be
reprocuring we're in the process of
reprocuring right now
so certainly no uh no impediments there
whatsoever
and the second thing i would just
underline is uh chan's point about
research for in the life sciences sector
and actually
you know there was a piece in the new
york times a few weeks ago
that was headlined uh
where is america's groundbreaking covid
19 research
the us could learn a lot from britain
i think that uh you know speaks uh
volumes about the way in which we have
had this uh
very agile response to uh research
treatments
and vaccine development in this country
and
long may it continue now i do want to
talk a bit about future pandemics but i
just want to get a few more audience
questions in first so
natalie asks what is the biggest failure
of this pandemic
um who would like to take that
um i i mean i i actually i actually do
think
that that question um we need more time
to answer that question
the reason i say that is not to sort of
deflect
an answer but is that we are in the
middle of phase two
right uh and throughout the globe there
is resurgence of clover 19 and i don't
think anyone has a sustainable model
to take us forward uh into into the
future years in terms of how do we
um combat covered 19 and the likelihood
is it will become endemic in the human
population
and become a potential seasonal virus i
mean that's yet to be determined
so therefore i think um understanding
you know the learnings the true
learnings in terms of clinical
aspects and the government government
response i think has to be done
when we're in a in a phase where we are
you know i suppose plateaued out in
terms of where we're going forward
so so i i'd rather say that at this
stage
it's really focusing on on what needs to
be done going forward
and um and later i think that there has
to be a look at
how we how we approach this i mean for
example i mean i think we do
need to look at um have a you know
generate data on on on the people that
sadly died during this
and see if there clinically was anything
more we could have done in terms of
of of you know treatments and in terms
of the
pathway that we initiated i mean um
and i i i think it's really important
that a lot of that is done
from the perspective of learning as
opposed to
uh pointing fingers and being accurate
because i think
as i said right about is unprecedented
right so we once we've known that a
pandemic is potentially coming i think
the reality of the pandemic
has taken almost all of us by surprise
you know um
i think very early much much earlier
than
when it started move on i also thought
that maybe we would have heard immunity
and this will be
you know something that when a certain
percent of the population
have had covid then the problem would
abate itself and it hasn't
um so so but i would say i mean i i
think if
i was pushed you know one of the key
things is we'd have to look at is
did we close borders fast enough and i
think when you look at
uh the couple of countries that have
have had
lower rates of infection and that they
the common theme seems to be
um that they close their borders very
quickly you know so
when when when who sort of call this a
pandemic
simon what do you think is the biggest
failure of the pandemic in terms of the
handling
well i think fundamentally the reason we
will have ended up
with um the deaths that we have had
is because we have much more coronavirus
circulating in the community
in february and march than was known
about at the time
and that in part is uh because of the
absence of testing it is partly
that the case definition that originally
attributed
uh coronavirus type symptoms to being
coronavirus if you had a travel history
uh from wuhan or china or uh when
actually
uh some of the genetic testing of the uh
coronavirus has shown that
uh much more of it came from uh france
and italy
uh across our borders rather than uh
originating
in china but fundamentally it's that we
ended up in a situation where
as the officers of national statistics
have estimated
i think seven out of ten of the working
age uh
adult uh coronavirus deaths occurred
um before uh early march uh
infection before early early march uh
before before lockdown so that
will turn out to have been a crucial
period now one question here from
drug which is what support should large
pharmaceutical companies
be giving to the nhs while we wait for a
vaccine chan what do you think of that
so um i think number one i i know our
focus has to be
um not only doing research vaccines but
research for other treatments potential
for kovid 19 so
so identifying i think also
in in medicines that we've already uh
produced
potential candidates that might be
working i think dexamethasone
you know is a classic example where you
know msd we launched that in 1950
and and i'm glad that it's still you
know sort of as clinical utility and has
been around
from my perspective that um
the the and then beyond that i think is
is going to
what simon describes is as the nhs makes
solutions in terms of the patient
pathway
you know improving diagnosis of other
things
improving um i suppose treatment
pathways is working with the nhs
to implement those new new pathways and
techniques
so there's a lot i think i think we can
do as a health community
to to work together i mean the the
answer won't really come from just
pharmaceutical companies um working with
the nhs it has to be a collaborative
approach from diagnostics
to to to also i suppose one group we
haven't really
spoke about is is charities and and
especially healthcare charities where
um the support of the patient i think
for me is paramount
i think going forward also um when we're
looking at this
the um
how fast we actually get sort of
innovative treatments through
is a key question i mean i think the the
regulation authorities have
you know bent over backwards i suppose
to in this sort of acute phase to try to
improve that and try to get access
to um you know supply chain medicines
from elsewhere
but i think as we look forward we need
we do need to look at how
quickly we can go through once we get
gain a license
to to introducing uh new innovative
medicines into into the patient pathway
simon what are your thoughts on this
you've mentioned i mean not directly
related
but in the past you know criticize those
drug firms which try and
price gouge the taxpayers so what
positive role can be played
well that's a that's a very unusual
particular circumstance i think you're
referring to
which is one particular company that has
uh
taken some uh generic lithium off-brand
and
uh attempted to hike the price by 2 600
percent
uh from three pounds 22 to 77 pounds so
but that is the
absolute exception rather than the rule
uh the the reality is actually we have a
very constructive and vibrant
partnership with uh
research-based uh uh life sciences
companies
and so i mean in terms of the research
priorities um we obviously want
more treatments for uh those who are um
acutely
and severely unwell with covid building
on what we've had with uh dexamethasone
and
hydrocortisone we've got rem deserve
there there are trials underway
on convalescent plasma there are two
monoclonal antibodies that are being
researched here as well
and there are some recent research
that's been published in the journal
science looking at whether there are
genetic or immunological defects that
explain
why certain patients go on to have a
worse uh coronavirus
uh experience uh clinically that if we
could get to the bottom of could be very
helpful as well so look there's there's
a
huge amount to be done here um and
that's before we get on to the vaccine
uh question and i hope that
the sort of improved clock speed from
regulators and
uh life sciences companies and nhs
trilists that we've seen over the last
six months can become the new normal
uh forever not just something that we do
uh in these terrible times
now i think it might be quite hard to
think about this but when we're looking
ahead to a potentially second wave
as at least i said some parts of the
country we're seeing that second wave
of coronavirus to think about what the
next one is but
when you read a very views of scientists
there is a sense among some this is not
actually the big pandemic there will be
more to come and actually they could
become more frequent
so i wondered given that the gates
foundation estimates that a global flu
pandemic if it hit now could
lead to 33 million um dead what
what should we be doing now can we start
to think about what the next pandemic is
or actually
is it something whether it just isn't
the capacity and i'm not sure who would
like to go first on that
uh i don't mind going first of all i
think going back to that question about
what could have done better i
you know when i qualified back in 96 um
the discussion of pandemics was going on
on then and i think then maybe we were
actually
perversely sort of it was more of an
intellectual debate and saying you know
is it avian flu is it sars and so forth
what i think has caught us by surprise
is we weren't prepared for this right we
weren't prepared for
understanding potentially where it could
come from i think we
loved ourselves into force and security
that with influenza we at least had
vaccines
to treat influenza and therefore you
know that we felt that was the biggest
threat
in terms of pandemic and we we had an
armament that could could help
combat that and i think you know the the
there are multiple real factors that are
pushing
other viruses and and potentially other
bacteria to become
pandemic uh creating um things so
so if i give an example i think you know
with potentially climate change
we're seeing certain diseases spread
wider across
across um different territories so um
and i think you know this is you know
ebola was a classic example where we
were seeing ebola
break out far more often and i think you
know that's also a great success story
for vaccines in terms of
having created uh vaccines on that but
things like dengue which is another
virus um
which infects sort of in into his blood
um
historically i mean when i was when i
qualified it was it was in about four
endemic in about four or five countries
it's endemic in over 100 countries now
and that potentially
is the the the mosquito that sort of
transmits it
having a wider range same with lyme
disease in in the uk i mean when i
again i might make myself sound like a
really old person but
when i go back to to you know when i was
quite effective there's very few cases a
rare
rare diagnosis and now it's a more
frequent diagnosis
so i think when we think about where
this is coming from
the solution should not only be um based
on looking at
you know viruses and and saying what it
is i think there's a greater societal
uh factors we need to take into account
not at least climate change you know so
so
so it will come and and that's a sad
fact of it but
we need a total response in terms of
combating it not just looking for new
vaccines not looking at
new sort of pandemic techniques
simon what would you add to that because
we clearly heard a lot about how
the nhs and the uk government had a
strategy for a pandemic it's just in the
end it turned out that the
pandemic we got was not the one that
matched that strategy
yeah i mean that's right so obviously
pandemic flu had been right at the top
of
uh sort of worldwide concern there have
been three
flu pandemics in the 20th century people
think back to the 1918-19
so-called spanish flu pandemic that i
think killed perhaps around 40 million
people then there was the asian flu
outbreak of
1957 and then the so-called hong kong
flew
1968 so people very concerned about
flu given the way in which the um
subtypes
can evolve and spread around
the world but i think uh as chairman
just said there are many other
infectious disease threats that aren't
uh influenza
and you know in the 1950s um infectious
diseases were a
sort of dying medical specialty now
quite obviously
they are front and center not least
given the interaction with some of the
other science that's been done around
immunology and
uh genomics so what what
what do we need to sort of be aware of
well i think the first thing is
the risk is going up as a result of
environmentally driven changes in the
interaction between
uh animals and humans and a lot of these
originate um in animals and then
spill over and then compound that with
the global interconnectedness that
we have which has always been a feature
by the way of uh pandemics
um spreading along trade routes that's
what happened uh
with the uh plague of the three plagues
that we've uh pandemics we've had in the
last 2000 years
so first and foremost we need a strong
surveillance
infrastructure globally and that's one
of the reasons why i think uh
the british government's done a very
smart thing by um
looking to uh strengthen the
way in which who works in this area
prime minister's announced
uh extra uh who funding
uh no doubt there'll be a discussion to
be had about how
that works uh with the proper reach into
every individual individual country and
then
over and above uh the surveillance over
and above the
uh tackling of the root causes of some
of these uh
likely risks then we're just going to
have to um
be investing sensibly in
some of the vaccines and other treatment
responses because i think
if you think about the economic damage
that has been done by
uh covid the cost of that relative to
the cost of pandemic preparedness
uh i think people will now see that
pandemic preparedness is a very
smart buy for not just this country but
for the world
do you think we are going to see much
more investment than in pandemic
preparedness in the future do you expect
um i do yes i think people will
understand i mean even if you think
about the you know economic consequences
of the last six months in this country
relative to some of the uh uh
sort of health and uh and public health
uh costs uh
if if by investing smartly you can
offset some of that
uh significant economic damage then that
would
constitute a very smart buy and i just
want to just on that briefly simon then
i want to get to the final
question really is do you worry at all
about obviously the
cost of social distancing the cost of
lockdown there's obviously the cost in
terms of
non-covered deaths but just the cost and
the drain on the economy that it's going
to be
we might get to a point where it's hard
to sustain the level of funding we
currently have in the nhs
if the economy shrinks
yes i mean this is obviously a huge
concern not just in this country but in
all countries that have been affected
uh you know the fact is that the nhs uh
depends on a vibrant uh uk economy um
i've sort of said previously that
when the british economy sneezes the nhs
catches a cold
um so yes this is uh this is very
important but
i think it cuts both ways i think the
nhs is going to be
a part of some of the leveling up
economic agenda that we're going to be
seeing over the next
five or ten years whether that's uh the
beneficial consequences of investment in
r d that we'd be talking about
whether it's the jobs that are going to
be created through the
uh construction sector for the uh 40 new
hospitals that we need to see across the
country
whether it's the opportunity for high
skill
jobs that the health and indeed social
care
sectors represent so we are um
both reliant on and a contributor to
british economic success
and now just final questions coming up
the track uh because we have four
minutes so probably too late to adding
uh one question which we've had from a
few people is ultimately about
we're talking about social distancing
and some you said it's one of the most
effective ways to
live with coronavirus to limit the
spread testing is obviously also a key
part
of that but yet there's been some really
quite um i suppose depressing figures in
terms of the current level of uptake
the number of people who are isolating
um
gee i wonder from both of you i mean do
you think i mean we can prepare all the
extra space in the nhs there is but
is it ultimately a it seems like quite a
big problem if you cannot get currently
you know public adherence to go much
above 20 on some of these things
so yeah sure well
actually if you think about how people
responded during the
uh sort of initial phases people were
incredibly
uh responsible and they looked out for
their
neighbors and their uh as well as their
friends
friends and relatives people uh
volunteered
um there was a huge sense that uh we're
all in this
together um understandably uh some
months on
uh we you know forget uh aspects of that
but
all i think those of us in health
service would say is
we're not doing this for the government
we're not doing this
because a law has been passed we're
doing it
for ourselves and each other and so
it's that sense of um our personal and
uh
shared responsibility that is uh
ultimately going to get us through this
and ultimately we we have not beaten the
pandemic
or the virus itself yet so we're all
still personal accountable to
supporting efforts to get there um and
it's very difficult to say when that end
point will be
um and moreover i think that
when you talk about we talk about
covered 19 isolation
but the the more endemic it is in in the
population
the more complications you will have in
other disease areas so for me
you know it's not just about um whether
our catch covered or not i think
by by using social distancing by taking
care
it is protecting the health of of
nation not just just about an infection
rate of covert 19.
and i would also just say katie just the
other thing on this
is this is not just about um you know
i'm uh
young and immortal uh in my 20s
um you know unfortunately the fact is we
are learning more about
so-called long covid about the ongoing
consequences that affect
people where they get multi-organ uh
disease on the back of the initial
infection so this is
you know this is an infection that needs
to be taken
very seriously uh and the consequences
are not just for other people but they
can unpredictably strike
yeah a long covert is something that
younger age groups need to worry about
too
yes and now final question
ultimately this discussion is titled the
nhs in a covered 19 world and i think
one thing a few people are asking is
how long is this going to be a covered
19 world
we have a situation where boris johnson
talks about six months more restrictions
uh pointing to either a vaccine or
operation moonshot which is a
mass rapid testing i wonder just to end
but for both of you i mean
how do you how long do you think this is
going to be a world where we are living
with coronavirus where coronaries are
dramatically
uh affecting and changing the health
service that we need
and and change you want to go first and
then we'll end with simon well i could
say
i think i think it's gonna be for a very
long time and i you know we are working
tirelessly to look for vaccines and
other treatments
but that that is some way still in the
future and i don't believe that we will
have
a one vaccine solution that you know
there's
you know data coming through that times
alludes to that means that the immunogen
geneticity of
of cover 19 may mean that vaccines may
not be the total solution
so hence we just have to make what we're
doing currently sustainable
and and something that is looking ahead
to the future
that allows us to uh live with the
threat of kovid 19 going forward and and
and and re-resurrect our daily life
alongside that um so so i i would say
you know what
it's it's a sort of depressing note to
end on um you know
we should just assume it's here for that
and i would say that other coronaviruses
you know are endemic in in the
population so so
covered 19 is not the only beta
coronavirus that
has got itself into the human population
and then become endemic
thankfully the other ones that do cause
very light disease
seven you get the final wedge well like
uh
like chan i think uh it's quite likely
that the sort of population on the
global level
uh uh covered 19 will be around
for um a long time but i'm perhaps a
little more optimistic that
um the back end of this year the first
part of next we will begin to see
vaccines that will
make a difference to people's risk
profile that together with
some of the wider mass testing
technologies will i think
mean that we can be much more targeted
and selective
in the responses that are being taken
and
finally i would say that as far as the
health service is concerned
i mean our message to patients uh which
we've been
trying to emphasize uh over the last uh
several months is not
uh you know stay away come what may our
message is
uh we are here we are open help us help
you
and the way in which you help us help
you is by coming forward and getting
that uh concerning lump checked out or
if you've got chest pain
uh your heart problem and we are open
and let's make sure that we sustain as
much
to that interaction as we possibly can
even as we head into winter
possible further spikes in covet
brilliant thank you so much to
my panel today it's been a really
interesting discussion i'm sorry you can
get to every question that was sent in
and too high demand which is never a bad
thing um so thanks again and thank you
to msd for sponsoring this discussion
i'm now going to leave it there and
exit the meeting and so thanks again
everyone